pues lo primero de todo efectivamente
Más allá de cómo de cómo se mueva la
cuestión de la moción que parece digamos
un escenario bastante improbable para
tumbar básicamente esta reforma Parece
ser que para el movimiento social
empieza un segundo acto empieza un
segundo acto en el que algunas voces
pues piden lo que llaman una chaleco
amarillización por lo tanto Pues
básicamente que se lleve digamos más
lejos Pues esta movilización en términos
de radicalización en términos de
presencia en las calles y entonces pues
se abre un escenario que para el
movimiento social no parece ser otro que
el de un escenario parecido al de la ley
del primer contrato de 2006 con sirac Es
decir de básicamente de intentar tumbar
mediante la movilización ciudadana Pues
básicamente esta reforma un poco como
pasó con los chalecos amarillos con La
retirada de laicotasa y el plan de los
13 mil millones de euros que tuvo que
poner a disposición el gobierno de
macron no entonces la movilización si la
movilización continúa es o hasta que el
gobierno regule y retire la reforma o
incluso La pregunta es si no es incluso
demasiado para que esta demanda
satisfaga digamos al movimiento social y
no estamos llegados digamos a un punto
en el que lo único que se espera es que
el gobierno termine por caer no Entonces
tendremos que ver si yo creo que las
semanas que vienen son determinantes e
incluso sobre todo a partir de después
del domingo después de ver lo que pasa
con con las emociones donde veremos si
tenemos los últimos coletazos del
orgullo del movimiento social o
realmente Una radicalización que
sobrepase a las direcciones sindicales
porque hay una aglutinación básicamente
de los enfados que puede incluso
sobrepasar a lo que las direcciones
sindicales desearían no precisamente
como usted dice no un movimiento
liderado hasta el momento por las
direcciones sindicales y usted hacía
paralelismo con que el movimiento se
dirija a una algo parecido a lo del de
los chalecos amarillos le pregunto hasta
ahora qué particularidades ha tenido el
movimiento contra las reformas y que
paralelismo Se podrían hacer con
movimientos precedentes
Bueno claro en este caso el movimiento
contra la reformas sí que ha estado pues
muy dirigido por el movimiento sindical
pero llegando digamos a capas a las que
no se lo iba a llegar el movimiento
sindical y eso es lo más importante
llegando a muchos asalariados o
trabajadores y trabajadoras del sector
privado que se que lo vemos en las
distintas encuestas por ejemplo llevadas
por los compañeros y compañeras de donde
vemos un gran apoyo y tanto tanto
simplemente
quedándose en sus casas pero también
yendo a las calles por parte de los
trabajadores y trabajadoras del sector
privado y en cambio Pues el movimiento
de los chalecos amarillos sí que pues no
evidentemente sabemos que no estaba
dirigido no estaba digamos acompañado
por el por el movimiento sindical no lo
que sí que es bastante comparable es que
ambos movimientos pues tienen una tasa
de apoyo social de la opinión pública
muy muy importante no y entonces pues
estará estará por ver ahora que sucede
con con la continuidad del movimiento
que sigue gozando básicamente esa
popularidad y por lo tanto de la de la
Reforma de Manuel macron y Aldo quizás
el de los chalecos amarillos es el
movimiento más emblemático el que más
recordamos del primer mandato de Manuel
macron sin embargo ha habido muchos en
términos generales qué podemos decir de
la relación del presidente con los
movimientos sociales que han
protagonizado sus años de mandato
claro yo creo que se ha caracterizado
por hacer oídos sordos básicamente ante
las demandas de los movimientos sociales
y por mantener con ellos pues un pulso y
una mano de hierro que parece dar la
razón a los chalecos amarillos que han
venido diciendo durante estos años de
que básicamente de que es un gobierno
que se dedica a pasar medidas pues
antipopulares antisociales y
pococráticas no entonces Pues un poco
revelando pues la crisis de la quinta
República y de su representación y yo
creo que pues lo hemos podido ver con
algunas de sus propuestas en términos de
participación por parte del gobierno de
macron hay que acordarse que para hacer
bajar la tensión del movimiento de los
tráficos amarillos propuso un gran
debate nacional en el que se recogieron
pues muchísimas respuestas a preguntas
importantes Aunque estuvieran dirigidas
por parte del gobierno o la convención
por el clima para responder también a la
creación el creciente enfado
efectivamente que existe también por la
cuestión climática y todas esas demandas
todo todo esa recogida de básicamente de
inteligencia popular han terminado
archivadas no entonces pues Incluso en
esta ocasión en que la estrategia
sindical al menos hasta el 7 de marzo
era lo que llamamos la estrategia
sindical de la escalera Es decir de ir
poco a poco aglutinar básicamente el
apoyo social de la opinión pública pero
sin bloquear el país donde hemos visto
que las direcciones sindicales no se
ponían muy de acuerdo sobre la
estrategia de la huelga donde las
huelgas totales pues han sido sobre todo
en el sector de la recogida de basuras y
de las refinerías y y vemos Que a pesar
de esta estrategia que de ir poco a poco
pues incluso con una estrategia así en
la que no se intentaba realmente
bloquear la economía Pues a pesar de
ello macron ha decidido pues no reunirse
con básicamente con con los bueno
básicamente con los actores sociales
entonces pues es verdad que bueno pues
el que en este caso el gobierno de
macron ha sido bastante bastante bueno
hacia otro lado no aldreber pues
estaremos atentos a Precisamente lo que
usted Decía si macron acaba reuniéndose
con los actores sociales o si continúa
con la estrategia
represiva contra el movimiento
Muchísimas gracias por su análisis y por
su tiempo